The European Union says soon, half of its
citizens will have been vaccinated against
COVID-19.
As infection rates go down, many countries
are slowly opening up.
Among them, the Czech Republic - where people
are coming back to its historic beer gardens
and evocative medieval cities.
But for many families there, life is not returning
to normal.
Their country suffered the highest death rate
in the EU – and they say that could have
been avoided.
This is their final farewell – COVID has
taken their bookstore and Marie's husband,
the local bookseller:
It was really sudden.
I hadn't expected it would hit my husband.
But in 9 days he was dead.
I thought about carrying on, but ahead of
us was a series of further lockdowns, and
we couldn't have sold anything.
This Shop was Jaromir Vytopil's life.
He was the Czech Republic's oldest bookseller.
Holding on to his profession throughout changing
political regimes, during the Prague Spring
and under Communism.
When the iron curtain fell he could finally
become proud owner of his own store.
Every morning before opening up he had coffee
and read the papers in this corner café.
Mr. Vytopil is a legend.
When you came into his shop for a book, just
a talk or a bit of advice – he always helped.
It was his passion, so much was clear.
But in November, with COVID raging unchecked
in the country, Jaromir fell gravely ill and
succumbed to the virus.
Now widow Marie and daughter Vera are picking
up the pieces.
Only a few boxes of books are left in the
family home:
We tried to protect ourselves from COVID,
but in a bookshop you can't stay behind the
counter… when a client needs help you have
to go and find the right book for them, and
maybe my husband forget to put on his mask
– I think that's how it happened.
But for many Czechs grief has turned into
rage.
Here in Prague protesters have covered central
the Old Town Square with thousands of white
crosses, one for each victim of the pandemic.
Activist Jacub Zevl believes government negligence
fueled the country's high death toll:
There were elections in the beginning of October
and obviously for PR its very bad to start
new restrictions for Covid, so they didn’t,
and let the epidemic grow and grow and grow.
Anger against authorities is increasing, adding
to the longstanding outrage increasing over
alleged corruption, and people are taking
to the streets
I think the government and Prime Minister
Babis have used the pandemic to foster their
own interests.
I think the Prime Minister has put his own
election campaign before he health of his
citizens, that makes me really angry
Back in Pehlrimov Marie has only family photos
to remind her of a long marriage and partnership
– all that Covid has taken from her.
The clients grieved with us, and that was
something really special.
They cried and brought us flowers.
It was such a sad goodbye.
For so many Czech families goodbyes came to
soon, amid the symbols of grief for a country
that lost part of its soul.